God became a human being.
>> Can I ask a question?
>> Yeah.
>> You said super You said he
>> the supreme God chose to be a man.
>> The supernatural God chose to become a
man. Yes, sir.
>> So God died.
>> God in human form as a man.
>> Same typical anti-rinitarian arguments.
Same typical.
It doesn't matter what the group is. If
you're an anti-initarian, believe Christ
is a man. Same arguments. God died. Now
watch here. died on a cross.
>> God died.
>> God in human form,
>> God can die.
>> God limited himself and became a human
being. And as a human being, he died.
>> It doesn't say that anywhere in the
Bible.
>> Oh, okay. Let me show you how to answer
that. You guys know how to answer this.
The assumption is this, right? The
assumption is this. And I'm not going to
go through the entire debate tonight.
We're going to listen to about the first
15, 20 minutes, and then we're going to
deal with John 8 as I promised, Lord
willing. But in the upcoming days, we
will go through this. I'll listen to it
thoroughly. Go to specific timestamps.
So we don't have to listen to the two
hours. Now remember
YouTube copyright law allows for fair
use of excerpts for educational
purposes. So now God died. I had to
answer this. It's one of the original
questions I had to answer because
Jehovah's Witnesses, Muslims all use
that argument. Right here I'm on a
larger screen.
I started, remember I told you this the
other day, writing full-time for Answer
Is Psalm 1999.
Pray the Lord allows me to be a man of
integrity, that I love Jesus, and I'm
forgiven. And I acknowledge that I need
my Lord to forgive me because by his
blood, not by my merits, I will enter
his presence, that I am around for
another 20 years for these girls if the
Lord carries
and glorify him. Now, see what's the
first question I answer? 1999 when I
wrote a series of answers to common
question claims. If she's God, how can
God die? That's the first on the list.
You see it?
Thank you, Palatine. The Lord bless you
and preserve you. I just hope
Rumble doesn't take 30% like YouTube
does.
See it right there.
What's the first question?
Jesus God, how can God die?
If you want to find it here, let me get
you the link. Download the article, save
it. Now,
the assumption is, let me explain to you
the hidden assumption under the
question. God is ever living. God is
ever living
and therefore cannot die. Assumption,
death means ceasing to exist.
Which for the life of me, I don't know
why they define death to mean ceasing to
exist, secession of life. I know there
are people who believe in soul sleep,
but that is not a biblical teaching. The
Bible does not teach when you die, you
cease to be consciously alive. That's
not a biblical teaching. The Bible
teaches against it.
And we have now medical facts backing up
what the Bible has said. You have a soul
and spirit that continues to exist when
your body dies. In fact, the reason why
your body dies is because your soul and
spirit leaves your body.
And near-death experiences confirm that.
In fact, the medical community because
of massive amount of near-death
experiences, out-of- body experiences
that have been right rigorously
authenticated, verified.
They even have journals where doctors
submit experiences, peer-review
journals. It's a branch of medicine now,
and it's accepted. They've even written
books. A book came out of Germany not
too long ago where a group of doctors
and they're not Christians by the way.
Some of them don't even believe in
Christianity say that we can now say
consciousness is separate from brain
activity. When the brain dies, the heart
stops. Humans continue to be conscious.
They're not calling it a soul.
Okay. They call it consciousness. Well,
what they call consciousness, we call a
soul. We call a spirit.
So yes,
God died a human death. Why? Because
that's the only death he could die. Why?
God as God. God is spirit. God is God.
How could he die?
God as man died. So God died a human
death.
without ceasing to exist. Let me repeat.
God died a human death without ceasing
to exist. Because God is God. God is
spirit. So what he was saying is right.
God is God. God is spirit.
How would he die?
You understand? But God as man died. So
God died a human death without ceasing
to exist. Because even when humans die,
they don't cease to exist.
Okay, everyone with me there? Everyone
got it? Now, let me give you some
receipts for my my boy, a son of his
right hand. So, yeah, Cliff is right.
God died a human death. God died as a
man. God died
a human death without ceasing to exist.
And our Lord himself proves it.
How do I know? He proves it here.
John 21:19-22. And I'm going to give you
now biblical proof that physical death
occurs because your soul leaves your
body. Your spirit leaves your body.
Well, if your soul and spirit leave your
body, where do they go? Well, that's the
thing. John 21:19-22
Jesus answered him, "Destroy this
temple, and I will raise it again in 3
days." The Jews replied, "It has taken
46 years to build this temple and you
are going to raise it in three days."
Question.
If Jesus wasn't consciously alive
during the three days, his body in the
tomb, how then did he can he say, "I I
myself will raise that temple," meaning
my body after you destroy it. It has
taken 46 years to build this temple. You
are going to raise it in three days.
Now, they misunderstood him. They
thought he's talking about the temple in
Jerusalem. But then John tells us, "But
the temple he had spoken of was his
body. The Lord Jesus says, I myself,
I myself will raise my body on the third
day."
How could he do that if he wasn't
consciously alive? So number one, he
must be consciously alive, but number
two, he must be God to raise his own
body
to life and not just revivify his body
makes his body immortal. He goes, I'm
going to do that. How could he, if he's
not God, how could he, if he's a
creature, raise his body and make it
immortal? Does that make sense?
Same Bible he believes in, right?
Does that make sense?
Watch this session I did on death and
the afterlife for full receipts on the
biblical teaching that when you die, you
don't cease to be conscious.
Now watch here. After he was raised from
the dead, his disciples recalled what he
had said. Then they believed the
scripture and the words that Jesus had
spoken. Now this dovetales with the
previous session where Jesus said and I
gave receipts
to show that no one could kill him, no
one could touch him, no one could get
near him because he could wipe them out
of existence by his word. Remember I
showed you that in John 18 verses 5-6.
Well, watch the previous session. I
started a playlist rumble. The playlists
are on YouTube for now. John 10:17 18.
The reason my father loves me is that I
lay down my life only to take it up
again.
I lay it down and then I take it up. Can
a mere human creature say, "I will take
my life up again after I lay it down. I
will allow myself to die and then I will
raise it up. No one takes it from me,
but I lay it down of my own accord."
Can a mere creature say, "No one can
take my life, my soul away from me. No
one can cause me to die. I have to
choose to die and then I will take it
up.
Note, this implies he's claiming to be
God. He says, "No one can take my life,
my soul from me." Well, the only way he
can say that and mean it if he's
almighty because no finite creature can
guarantee that no other creature,
especially one stronger than him, won't
kill him and take his life away. Here it
shows that Christ is claiming to be
almighty
and claims that he must be consciously
alive for him to raise up his life after
he voluntarily allows himself to be put
to death. I have authority lay it down
and authority take it up again. This
command I receive from my father. So my
father sent me with this command to lay
my life down for the salvation of the
world.
So, how does this refute the deity of
Christ when it establishes the deity of
Christ? I don't get it.
Right. Rumble Jesus living God toxic.